police in Ferguson are now marching
alongside demonstrators and a bid to
ease tensions they've also been
releasing more details about the deadly
incident the officer that was involved
in the shooting of Michael Brown was
Darren Wilson he's been a police officer
for six years has had no no disciplinary
action taken against him he was treated
for injuries which occurred on Saturday
almost a week later police now say the
victim was suspected of stealing a box
of cigars from a convenience store but
some residents accused police of
fabricating the allegation in order to
cast doubt on the victims character why
is it so long imma say anything about a
robbery when no personnel or no business
and necklace claiming to be robbed so
now all of a sudden somebody got robbed
because ever been to be losing so now
you can say it's a robbery because who
gonna know the exact circumstances of
the shooting are still unclear but the
incident triggered days of unrest in
Ferguson outrage over police methods has
spread far beyond the Midwestern town
with solidarity rallies and cities
across the u.s.